we begin with the high stakes diplomacy
in geneva switzerland where u.s
president joe biden
and russia's president vladimir putin
have concluded their first
face-to-face summit both leaders have
described the nearly four hours of talks
as
being positive and cordial but there
remain areas of deep
division president putin denied that
moscow was responsible for recent cyber
attacks
on u.s institutions he also brushed
aside criticism of russia's human rights
record
including the jailing of opposition
leader alexei navalny
u.s president joe biden spoke about the
reason for this face-to-face meeting and
what he wanted
to make clear to president putin and
president putin and i
had a share unique responsibility
to manage the relationship between two
powerful and proud countries
a relationship that has to be stable
and predictable and it should be able to
we should be able to cooperate where
it's in our mutual interest
and where we have differences i want to
president putin understand
why i say what i say and why i do what i
do
and how we'll respond to specific to
specific kinds of actions
that harm america's interest just before
that
russian president vladimir putin was
asked what he thought about u.s
president joe biden
here's what the russian president had to
say
if you ask me what kind of a person and
interlocutor
president biden is i can say that he is
a constructive person
well balanced and experienced seasoned
politician and i expected that
he recalled his family
and conversations he had with his mother
well these things don't have
directly something to do with our
business but nevertheless
it shows his qualities and his moral
values
it is all appealing and i believe that
we spoke the same language
it doesn't necessarily mean that we need
to look into the eyes and see the soul
and to pledge eternal
love we defend the national interests
of our countries and this relationship
are always based on pragmatism
all right we want to go down to our very
own terry schultz she's covering this
summit for us in geneva switzerland good
evening to you
terry if if you look at the whole summit
this meeting which went almost four
hours i mean
how would you describe it can we say
that this was a successful
summit and if so for whom
i think we can brent because both
presidents came out of the meeting
telling
admittedly their sides of the stories
but similar versions of the story of the
topics that got discussed
uh they both said that they had
explained what their red lines were to
the other side
and that the other side had understood
that so that already is a
move forward in terms of transparency
president biden acknowledged that
you know some of the things they talked
about like moving ahead on
on possibly ending some of these cyber
attacks that we know
are backed by the kremlin he said he's
not sure that
that those will be stopped but that at
least talking about them raises that
possibility and one interesting thing he
said is that
is that he believes that president putin
is concerned about his credibility in
the world his standing in the world
and that possibly solving some of these
problems with the united states
might help that i want to ask you about
the red lines that
people have been talking about
particularly these cyber
attacks do we know after these talks
what would happen
if these cyber attacks in the united
states continue do we know what
president biden
plans to do as a response
i don't think we know specifically yet
he was pressed on that
in the news conference that took place
after the meeting he was asked what
exactly
would you do and he wouldn't he wouldn't
get into it specifically but he did
emphasize time and again that he had
made sure president putin knows there
would be a response
just something i would add from my life
covering nato brent is that
cyber is now an article 5 level offense
so
countries under nato have the right to
respond in a manner of their choosing to
cyber attacks and president putin knows
that well so
i would imagine that president biden may
have alluded to that when he was talking
about
what could happen if these cyber attacks
continue and
both of these presidents said that there
had been no threats made
during their talks but you have to
wonder
what what is the world going to do now
are we just going to wait and see
what happens are we going to wait and
see if but
putin does what biden asked him to do i
mean is that the mode that we're in now
i'm not sure but i think possibly there
will be a period now
of waiting to see if if the not
pledges so much but understandings that
that were brought about by this meeting
do take effect and i think cyber is one
of those areas where we will see very
quickly because there have been just
almost constant cyber attacks some of
them huge and very crippling on the
united states
and this is another interesting thing
president biden said he said that he
thought people in the room there in
their larger meeting
began to understand that this could very
much hurt russia directly
if these cyber attacks were to continue
if for example
when when you know fuel supplies are
harmed in the united states that will
definitely come around to affect moscow
as well
and we know that at summit's symbolism
is very
important we know that the white house
did not want there to be
a you know a shared or joint press
conference this time between the two
presidents as was the case back in 2018
in helsinki
you were in helsinki when that summit
took place between putin and then
president
trump um talk to me about the the
differences what struck you today
if you think about what it was like in
2018
well when president putin's press
conference went on so long you could
sort of understand why president biden
would not have been wanting to
stand there next to him and certainly
listen to president putin bring up
criticism of the united states and and
human rights in in the united states but
thinking back to helsinki that was
honestly a circus that press conference
i remember you had
uh president biden give uh give
president
trump a gift of of a ball which he
tossed out to
to the audience and everyone said oh my
gosh there's got to be a listening
device in that ball i mean there were
just
moments like this that were truly
literally jaw-dropping at that press
conference hearing president trump say
he trusted
uh putin over his own intelligence
agencies
nothing like that happened at this very
sober press conference today
and i don't think anyone could have
imagined president biden acting this way
yeah you have a very good memory though
i think it was a soccer ball that was
given to trump and i think the white
house
confirmed that it was checked for any
bucks terry schultz
in geneva terry thank you
and our coverage continues here at the
big table with our chief international
editor richard walker richard
what would you say what were the main
takeaways from this summit
yeah well i think i mean the contrast
couldn't be
clearer could it as as terry's example
shows
and i think really you have a sense of
sort of so far so good
you know the relationship between the us
and russia both sides did agree on this
that it was
pretty much at its lowest level since
the the end of the cold war and
it's hit some pretty deep lows during
that time
and the two leaders came out in their
separate con
press conferences really delivering
essentially quite similar messages about
the key agreements and the key steps
that had been agreed to there wasn't
like you know joe biden didn't come out
and say everything that vladimir putin
just said is nonsense he actually
indicated a couple of times in his press
conference that he'd been watching
vladimir putin and really didn't
contradict anything and now
there are steps which are taken in a
couple of areas particularly in this
area of strategic stability and we can
talk about that in a moment
um where they've started a dialogue and
they've
you know they've made some pretty bold
statements for instance
you know a joint presidential statement
from the kremlin and from the white
house saying that nuclear war cannot be
won
and must never be fought and kind of
recommitting the two sides
to this idea of arms control which is
something that has been really kind of
almost on its last legs the last few
years several arms controlled treaties
one side is either pulled out or they've
expired um
and the two sides saying actually no we
really kind of have to deal with this
stuff
and that's a change that is a change and
it's important to hear that
but at his press conference president
putin when asked about the cyber attacks
coming from russia targeting the u.s he
again denied
any responsibility for that so with that
the story hasn't changed one bit coming
from the kremlin yeah and that
i mean that's going to be one of the
tests of this year if the two sides are
recommitting to arms control
we're not in those old days of the you
know up to the 1980s and
you know some uh treaties which came
beyond that
where you're really saying okay big
nuclear weapons how many do you have of
which type
you know and try to get the numbers down
in the era of cyber war and other
high-tech
aspects of the military ai weapons
uh autonomous weapons stuff like that
you know where algorithms
you know uh the the other tools of the
weapons
you can't count those so you have to
come up with new ways of
of of dealing with these like how do you
come up with agreements about
you know what you cannot can and cannot
do what are your capabilities in the
cyber realm
so it's not going to be so much about
what you are capable of doing
it's what you choose to do and what you
agree to do or not do
but even that is difficult because in
the world of cyber you know
everything is deniable no it's not
absolutely
like cast iron you can say like a
missile it's just landed well i know
where that came from yeah
there's some psychology here too at play
um it seems like
president biden is giving is trying to
give putin we know this respect that
putin
wants so badly by suggesting
in in the press conference that he's the
president of russia
and he has the power and the authority
to control
you know his defenses and his weapons
and the cyber infrastructure
of his country so he's trying to give
something
to putin so that putin will also give
him the predictability of
saying there will be no more attacks
would you agree with that well yeah i
mean i think
biden was trying to kind of cast a new
level of respect
you know obama made the mis the mistake
of once referring to russia as a
regional power
and this was seen as you know this was
this was seen as a diplomatic mistake
you know this only made vladimir putin
want to prove his own power more
donald trump went in the opposite
direction he sort of flattered putin it
was almost bizarre
um what joe biden said in the early part
of his
uh press conference saying that you know
these two nations have a unique
responsibility because they have the
largest nuclear arsenals they both have
thousands of nuclear weapons even china
only has hundreds it is a totally
different level
and as proud nations it's their
responsibility to deal with that
that that will have been you know a
really carefully judged message
vladimir putin i'm showing you respect
you know the it was the
the whole event was a signal of respect
um
so biden will certainly be hoping that
this influences vladimir putin's um
behavior but biden himself said you know
don't watch
really what's happening now and this is
really good with the test what comes in
the next three to six months they're
setting up these working groups they're
setting up dialogues to look at these
things
do they actually come up with concrete
conclusions are they able to find areas
where they can say all right yeah we can
kind of agree on limits or
or patterns of behavior around these
things or does that begin to unravel
what happens in ukraine that's a dynamic
situation where you know
things could happen you know so there's
going to be an awful lot to monitor
really the next few months but
like i said at the beginning i think
kind of so far so good
all right our chief international editor
richard walker richard as always
thank you